the British Council is taking your
lessons online hello everybody welcome
to the lesson be excited virtual lessons
are like any other classroom lessons at
the British Council you will practice
your speaking great natural language and
your writing but everyone right there
wants with a chance you'll do all this
with your teachers and your classmates
in real time oh I can already hear you
thinking yeah this all sounds good but
online classes won't be as interactive
boss you will be doing pair work morning
good afternoon what does great really I
thought it was okay so how does it work
you'll need a computer a microphone a
camera and a good Wi-Fi connection can
you hear me now
can you hear me now can you hear me now
make sure it's a good Wi-Fi connection
you probably have access to all four of
these whilst watching this video so well
that you're all set to join your virtual
English lesson pretty good job well done
everybody just think about it
british council english lessons from the
comfort of your own home you won't need
to take public transport I think that's
it from us we're done if you do have any
questions don't hesitate to contact your
local british council center we look
forward to seeing you online very very
soon bye
[Applause]